both leaders had very different agendas
let's return to the President Putin
speech for a moment did he make any
mention in terms of sanctions did it
come across that he needed sanctions to
end he didn't make a powerful case for
ending them he said the sanctions have
been responsible external threats that
have caused some problems but they've
weathered them they've stabilized and
now it's time for you investors to come
back and look at all the things we're
going to do and I would say well where
have you been all of these years that
you've been in power and you're now
talking about having an educational
system that promotes investment in
technology and to become a world-class
economy they've got brilliant scientists
this great human capital intellectual
capital in Russia question is are they
going to be structural reforms in Russia
to eliminate the the corruption the
oligarchs and the rule of law as opposed
to the law of rule of President Putin
secretary Cohen I was struck by that as
well really talking about vocational
training HR training improving the
quality of mid-level managers
encouraging small and medium enterprises
encouraging non-raw exports these are
things as you say that Russia could have
been doing for two decades exactly since
the last time you were negotiating with
them in 1997 we also have Andrews core
with us on the desk Anders you know we
your ears sort of perked up when you
heard the word Eurasian Union right I
mean what Putin is trying to do is he's
trying to close ranks with China he's
trying to close ranks with the other
former Soviet republics and he wants to
create he really wants to go back to an
old Warsaw block approach to economics
where where Russia and its allied
countries were impervious to US and
European sanctions that's what he's
doing he's looking at a non-target
Arctic economic system where trade is
happening between these autocracies and
they can then really act with impunity
on their borders on their territorial
and borders in terms of expansion
expansion of influence and not worry
about economic sanctions from the West
see secretary Cohen he also talked about
the Silk Road I thought that was
interesting that he made explicit
mention of that there two ways to look
at that you know one is there is going
to be more cooperation between Russia
and China the other is we have our
sphere of influence is if you recognize
that we recognize what you're doing
that's your sphere this is ours well
it's interesting you look at the lineup
following the Greek Prime Minister you
also had Shawn Galilee one of the most
powerful figures in China over the top
seven as such he was speaking a third in
line I think his message will be mutual
respect equal responsibility border
security type of thing and so his
position in the lineup is very important
the signal saying that we're with Russia
in terms of promoting better trade
relationships with the big powers these
market is incredibly important to Russia
obviously if Russia is not selling its
gas and oil to Europe it's got to sell
it to Russia and that's what we already
see so that Silk Road is incredibly
important it's gonna be silt dipped in
oils what it is under is Prime Minister
tsipras you know some gang get a pretty
confident speech as well European
leaders will have been watching that
though did he get any kind of message of
course he said people were asking him
why he was in Russia and he's exploring
other avenues the message I get from tip
hrus is not one that's it's actually
between the lines he was speaking to her
Russian audience you'd expect that he
would say strong pro-russian Thanks
actually he did not he really walked a
middle line he walked a tightrope
between Russia and the European Union
and I think that by walking that
tightrope in that context we're really
seeing that he wants to stay with the
European Union the the what he's doing
is actually akin to diplomatic terrorism
by going to that by going to Russia and
and threatening playing footsie with
Russia I think it's unfortunate that the
ECB gave in to that economic that
diplomatic terrorism by immediately you
know raised the LA ceiling we should
just recap that by three billion
which we got some you know a week or two
but it's not exactly a huge and that is
huge that you know we the year the ECB
is not supposed to be a political
institution but that was absolutely a
political decision give reefs just
enough time for this negotiation to
happen we're gonna go to Hans Nichols
and Luxembourg in a little bit on that
but first let's go to Ryan Chilcott in
st. Petersburg Ryan I was struck hearing
words like well of course there was a
classic Vladimir Putin tweak he quoted
the price of oil in Euros but not
dollars but he also said the word
adapted that the finance system has
adapted that since the sanctions were
where were instituted that they have
been focusing on actual non raw goods
exports has the Russian economy now that
has had several months to respond is it
actually in the process of rebalancing
the Russian economy is not rebalancing
there's no doubt about that I mean
rebalancing I guess would involve
diversification we haven't seen any of
that there's a lot of talk about the
need for the Russian economy to
diversify what we have seen is a little
bit of the panic that we had last year
say at this forum when the first round
of sanctions had just been introduced
after the eidetic station of Crimea
that's gone away and you know the
economy is as they keep saying in a
little bit better shape than some people
thought it might be that's kind of a
loaded statement to be fair Brendon
because if you think about it who are
these people the economy is still in
really bad shape it's set to contract by
four percent you know the oil price
Brent sixty three bucks really bad for
Russia this means you know that real
incomes will fall pensions which have
been indexed to inflation for the last
decade that can't happen anymore I mean
inflation in this country is at sixteen
percent so it's a way to kind of change
the narrative things are you know raw
but they're not nearly as rough as they
could have been and I think that's the
focus here he's trying to control the
narrative and as far as the sanctions
are concerned say hey we've readjusted
you can keep your sanctions in place as
long as you want we're playing ball in
Ukraine we're not going to change what
we're doing in Ukraine anyway because
it's not us and by the way we've you
know sorted things out here at home so
the
really hurting us we're open for
business why don't you just you know be
friends with us that's his message who
Ryan Chilcote in st. Petersburg saying
that Russia's economy is still very much
based on gas and oil it is not a
manufacturing economy as he would like
to describe it we have secretary former
Secretary of Defense William Cohen with
us on the desk did Russia miss a chance
was there a time in the late 90s in the
early 2000s when it could have chosen a
different path or is this inevitable
well it could have chosen the path that
Poland did to make a transformation in
its approach to establishing a democracy
having a market economy they missed that
chance now what Putin is saying is we're
going to do that now and it's a bit late
at this point in time did you get the
sense in the late 90s when you were
speaking with them that that was a real
possibility well I did I also was
dealing with in talking to Boris Yeltsin
at the time President Gorbachev who was
talking about perestroika glass nose so
there was a sense at that time that here
you have a big country a great country
with brilliant people there was an
opportunity at that point to make the
transformation to a market economy into
democracy till my return
sheíll Oxenberg we have Hans Nichols
standing by there and point out that the
euro is down about half a percent the
ruble weakening substantially during
that speech Hans who will have been
listening to that we had some headlines
from jean-claude juncker is speaking
about Cyprus as he was speaking to the
audience in st. Petersburg well what
leaders want to hear from tsipras is
some sort of indication that he is going
to come to the table on Monday with new
proposals and there's been no indication
and there wasn't an indication from
Moscow that he plans to do so one quick
note guys on European the emergency
liquidity assistance out of the ECB we
still don't have a firm number for how
much it was raised by the request was
for three billion we don't know whether
or not the ECB Governing Council satisfy
that request met that request that is
going to be a key number to try to
figure out and the next couple of
minutes if not hours guys Hans Nichols
travelling all over Europe now at
Luxembourg thank you for joining us you
will of course be somewhere else when
the negotiations move on
somewhere else over the course of the
weekend Ryan Chilcote in st. Petersburg
during us live coverage from the st.
Petersburg International Economic Forum
thank you both on the desk we have
William Cohen former Secretary of
Defense real quick ten seconds or less
did Putin accomplished what he set out
to accomplish in this speech I don't
think so I think he said what he had to
say but it wasn't powerful or persuasive
to me and as vani pointed out the ruble
is actually dropping during his speech
so very specifically we have actual
measurement of the fact that he is not
getting it done
equity markets though just slightly
positive both in Athens and in Russia